Bueno estamos llegando ya al final de
este programa directo a América aquí en
France 24 pero antes tenemos todavía La
Crónica de economía con Juan Pablo y
Juan Pablo bienvenido de nuevo vamos a
hablar de Estados Unidos porque el dato
de la inflación se ha conocido esta
mañana que nos dice ese dato Así es pues
a 5% llegó la inflación anual de Estados
Unidos interanual en marzo desde el 6%
interanual de febrero lo que representa
un enfriamiento continuo de la economía
estadounidense que viene por lo menos
desde junio de 2022 cuando estaba en el
9,1% y que pues atribuye a esa política
monetaria estricta de la reserva Federal
es Entonces el noveno mes consecutivo de
desaceleración un dato que no sorprende
a los mercados que esperaban un
enfriamiento Y que ahora pone atentos a
todos los escenarios bursátiles a las
decisiones pues más tarde de la reserva
Federal la reserva Federal que
últimamente está en Boca de todos en la
economía vamos ahora con Los indicadores
de los mercados mundiales y vamos
precisamente con Los indicadores porque
como sabemos Pues el dato de inflación
afecta a todos los mercados mundiales
vamos principalmente con hacia las
bolsas cerraron mixtas de forma general
los mercados de ese sector estaban
atentos a los datos de inflación de
Estados Unidos y trataron en ese momento
de descifrar el estado de la primera
Economía del mundo evidentemente
acertaron porque esperaban un dato de la
caída en la inflación de Estados Unidos
en Europa que sigue operando también
pues movidas por el dato de inflación de
Estados Unidos dio el resultado de París
Frankfurt y Londres con ganancias y con
una tendencia alcista de forma general
Bueno pues vamos ahora con malos datos
de nuevo para las aerolíneas
latinoamericanas Ahora hay un anuncio
que afecta a ciudadanos de Colombia y de
México de qué se trata Rodrigo pues
especialmente para aquellos que
frecuentaban la ruta Bogotá Ciudad de
México porque a partir de el 19 de abril
la aerolínea wingo que opera en Colombia
suspenderá esta ruta de su oferta la
aerolínea aseguró que las retiradas de
las tres rutas semanales que es con el
objetivo de disponer esos aviones para
corresponder a la demanda de rutas
nacionales que ofrece y para cubrir las
nuevas rutas que recientemente abrió
como las dos que abrió en agosto desde
ciudad de Panamá a la Habana ciudad de
Panamá a Santo Domingo o pues la más
reciente una desde aruba hacia Cali que
pues ya dijimos que usted está
comprometido a conocer prontamente bueno
es que ya conozco con Cali ha estado dos
veces me encanta salvo porque a veces
hace demasiado calor pero muy bonita
Cali Entonces qué soluciones o
alternativas presenta wingo para los
turistas que ya tienen tiquetes
comprados vamos a verlas la aerolínea
dijo que ya avisó a las autoridades de
Colombia y México sobre el cambio y
propuso lo siguiente número uno cambiar
de ruta sin cobro de penalidad para para
estas personas solicitar también el
reembolso del 100% del valor de tiquete
y una compensación adicional equivalente
al 30% de la tarifa aérea este pago Se
puede obtener en un voucher o en la
forma pues del pago del tiquete por
último Los viajeros de abril podrán
solicitar la opción de a través de Copa
Airlines para volar al destino la
aerolínea se ha desembarcado de que
piensen que el anuncio se trata de una
debilidad financiera de la compañía e
incluso el 30 de marzo publicó en sus
redes sociales un código de protección
para viajeros afectados por el cierre de
la aerolínea de bajo costo Ultra Air
pues estaremos muy atentos porque aquí
en Colombia ya ha habido también muchos
problemas con el cierre de viva Air
vamos a seguir atentos como digo a lo
que pase con wingo nos vamos hasta
Irlanda del Norte hasta allá ha viajado
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden además una persona estadounidense
pero con raíces en Irlanda habló allí de
la importancia de la economía en la
región Así es su principal objetivo de
este viaje es garantizar que el acuerdo
negociado en 1998 permanezca en su lugar
y fue algo que el mandatario confirmó en
su discurso dijo que Irlanda del Norte
era gran potencial económico que Estados
Unidos seguirá siendo socio estratégico
y que en realidad siempre lo ha sido y
motivó a los emprendedores a invertir
más en la región el Primer Ministro
británico Richie sunak ya programó una
cumbre de inversión de Irlanda del Norte
para septiembre de este año y pues con
el objetivo de aprovechar los 1900
millones de dólares que las empresas
estadounidenses han invertido durante
los últimos 10 años biden ha designado a
Joe Kennedy III un descendiente de la
dinastía política irlandesa
estadounidense como su enviado comercial
a Irlanda del Norte desde luego una
muestra de que se lo tomaron muy en
serio Juan Pablo Muchas gracias mañana
con mucha más economía seguimos con
economía
[Música]